I do generally agree with the President
of the United States we've achieved some
major advances when it comes to
defeating the terrorists and we have
struck major blows and terrorists in
Syria there is a danger that those
terrorist groups might now infiltrate
the neighboring regions for example
Ganis 10 and other countries and also to
other countries for example their
countries of origin and this poses a
great risk for all of us including
Russia and the US for Asian countries
and the Central Asian countries and we
yes Donald Trump is right about that
American forces I'm not sure about what
that is the American forces have been
present in Afghanistan for what some 17
years and every year they talk about
withdrawing their forces from
Afghanistan but they're still present
there that's my second point and my
third point we do not see any signs of
the American withdrawal from Syria but
we see that it is possible and we are
now on the track of political settlement
you